LEADER RAILS NOTICES THE ABSENCE
OF A QUORUM. CALDERON
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BUT OUR
QUE HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA
BRIAN CALDERON RUBIO CERVANTES
CHEN CHOI COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY DAVIES
FLORA FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KILEY LACKEY LIII
LEVINE LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA. MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA QUINN
O'DONNELL ANDERSON PETRIE-NORRIS
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RADIUS
LOOSE. ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO
SMITH STONE TEAM VALIDATORS V.
APPROVED WA VOEPEL WALDRON LORD
WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN MOM YES DEAR FONG. IMAM. IN THE NAME OF GOD. THE MOST
GRACIOUS THE MOST MERCIFUL.
ALMIGHTY GOD. CREATOR AND RULER
OF THE UNIVERSE. EXCEPT OUR
PRAISE AND THANKS FOR YOUR HELP
IN OUR LIVES. REMIND US THAT
YOUR POWER IS CHIEFLY SHOWN
THROUGH ACTS OF LOVE AND MERCY.%
IN THE DAY TO DAY CONTEXT OF OUR
PRESENT LIVES. DIRECT AND
EMPOWER US MIGHTY GOD. TO BE
PART OF A PRESENT SO MARKED BY
ACTS OF LOVE AND MERCY. THAT THE
FUTURE OF THE STATE BE SHAPED BY
YOUR LOVE. BLESS THE MEMBERS AND
STAFF OF THIS CHAMBER. THEIR
FAMILIES AND ALL WHO VISIT HERE
TODAY WITH YOUR LOVE AND
PRESENCE I MEAN. THANK YOU WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US IN
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
MINORITY LEADER AT REPUBLICAN
LEADER GALLAGHER AS HE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE. SALUTE SLUDGE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SACRAMENTO MONDAY JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO RECENTLY
MET AT ONE PM THE AUDIBLE KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE AB
SIMPLY PRESIDING CHEAP LUXURY
PROGRAM THE- REFLECTIVE BILL
MURRAY WILL CALL THE ROLL WAS
CALLED THANK WELL THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM OVER QUORUM CALL
THE ASSEMBLY CARE TIME WHEN
SEVEN PM. THE SPEAKER PRO TEMP
DIRECT THE STATEMENT ON THE
BRING ANY OUT. ONE PRESENT ONE
TWENTY P. SUPER TO MORE TO CLEAR
THE COURT IN THE ROLE PUBLICLY
THE FOLLOWING AFTER TO THE
SEVENTY SIX AT WORK OF RAM OKAY
HIM BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW.
BONTA HOPE BOB BRO BURKE
CALDERON TO CERVANTES CHIN.
COOLEY COOPER. THE DAILY DAY
FLOOR FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER GARCIA PART OF A GETS
GREAT WHO OR JONES SAWYER KILEY
LACKEY LEE LIVED LOW. MATHIS
MAYES MEDINA MULLIN RESEARCH IN
THIS AREA WHEN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS SQUARE
WORKSHOP RAMOS WAS MISTER. A
SECOND THE THREE OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED. WITH
AND THEN PUT. THERE ARE NO.
ENTER AND OF WILL BE. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE. THERE ARE NONE. MOVING
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY IT WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. THIS RARE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE. TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS FLORHAM KALRA
COOLEY AG WE ARE CURRY BLUMEN
GIPSON. TO SPEAK ON IN GERMAN
AND MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY EIGHT AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR'S I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO STRIKE ALL REMAINING
GOVERNOR'S VETOES FROM THE FILE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH TEN INCLUSIVE
. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MOVING TO
THE BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MR KILEY FOR WHAT PURPOSE DO
SEEK RECOGNITION. A GOOD
MORNING- MADAM SPEAKER. GOOD
MORNING COLLEAGUES. I KNEWFOR A
RULES SUSPENSION IN ORDER TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY SIX TO BE TAKEN
UP IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT REFERENCE
TO FILE. A MOTION TO SUSPEND THE
RULES REQUIRES A SECOND IS THEIR
SECOND. MR FLOOR SECONDS. THE
MOTION IS NOT DEBATABLE IT TAKES
THIRTY EIGHT VOTES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY IT IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE THE MAJORITY LEADER IS
ASKING FOR A NOBLES THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL THOSE
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE DESIRED ABOUT. ALL THOSE
VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE THE MAJORITY LEADER IS
ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE. YOUR.
THE. THE CLERK OKAY HELLO THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES IS HAVE
FIFTEEN KNOWS HAVE FORTY EIGHT
THE MOTION TO SUSPEND THE RULES
FAIL. THE STATE YOUR POINT OF
ORDER. THIS RESOLUTION HAS BEEN
AT THE DESK FOR OVER A YEAR-
AND- YET HAS NOT BEEN REFERRED
AND THAT IS NOT THE WAY I THE
PROCEDURES OF THIS BODY OR
SUPPOSED TO WORK. MR KILEY THE
HOUSES VOTED THE MOTION FAILS WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE DAILY
BUSINESS. YOUR POINT IS NOT
TWELVE TAKEN. MR KILEY HAS
APPEALED THE DECISION OF THE
CHAIR THIS MOTION REQUIRES A
SECOND IS THERE A SECOND. WHO.
MISTER MATHIS SECONDS. AT MR
KILEY YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER- AS I
SAID IN THIS RESOLUTION HAS BEEN
SITTING AT THE DESK AFTER A YEAR
IT IS TIME FOR THIS LEGISLATURE
TO STEP UP AND- AND PLAY ITS
ROLE IN OUR CONSTITUTIONAL FORM
OF GOVERNMENT THE REALITY IS
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN A SO CALLED
STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR ALMOST
TWO YEARS NOW AND THIS WEEKEND
OF THIS COMING WEEKEND WE'RE
GONNA BE SEEING. SCENES LIKE
THIS ONE. AS CALIFORNIA. WILL BE
HOSTING THE SUPER BOWL. DURING A
STATE OF EMERGENCY WHAT IS IT
AGAIN CALIFORNIA IS HOSTING THE
ACTUAL SUPER BOWL DURING A STATE
OF EMERGENCY. IT IS TIME TO END
THE ABSURDITY AND THAT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA GIVE BACK
TO THEIR LIVES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF OUR CAN STATE YOUR POINT OF
ORDER. MR KILEY PLEASE CONTINUE. IT IS TIME THAT WE ANY
ABSURDITY AND I TO URGE MY
COLLEAGUES. ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE TO DO A MEMBERS OF
YOUR PARTY OF DONE IN OTHER
STATES. AND THE EMERGENCY AND
ALL RESTRICTIONS AND ALL
MANDATES THAT'S WHAT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA MOVE ON WITH THEIR
LIVES THANK YOU. I STAND BY MY
RULING THE QUESTION BEFORE THE
BODY IS SHALL THE DECISION OF
THIS IS SPEAKER BE SUSTAINED THE
SPEAKER IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MR KILEY IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. WHAT THE VALUABLE. ALL
THOSE VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS IT TAKES A MAJORITY OF
THOSE PRESENT AND VOTING TO
SUSTAIN THE CHAIR THE SPEAKER IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. ALL
THOSE VOTE TO DECIDE ABOUT.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE OF.
WHICH IS. BY. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I HAVE FORTY SIX KNOWS HAVE FOR
FIFTEEN THE SPEAKER IS THE STATE. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MISTER. THE HERE RECONSIDERATION
ITEMS UNDER CONSIDERATION SHALL
BE CONTINUED. ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING ITEMS SHALL BE PASSED
ENTERTAINED. SENATE THIRD
READING WE HAVE ONE MEASURE ON
THE SENATE THIRD READING TO TAKE
UP TODAY MISTER BRIAN IS A FLOOR
MANAGER FOR FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
SB FIVE OH FOUR MISTER BECKER
MISTER BRIAN. ARE YOU READY TO
PROCEED. YES MA'AM. GOOD MORNING
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHTS HAVE A SENATE JOHN HODGES
THIS RAIN THE CLERK WILL READ
THE BILL SENATE BILL FIVE OH
FOUR BY CENTER BECKER AND
ACCOLADES REFLECTIONS IN THE
CLEAR THE AIR SEEDER UP
SIGNIFICANTLY. MISTER BRIAN YOU
MAY OPEN THE MEASURE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE
RISING THEY HAVE A SENATOR.
BACKGROUND SB FIVE OH FOR SB
FIVE OH FOR THE BIPARTISAN VOTER
REGISTRATION MEASURE SPONSORED
BY OUR STATE CLERK AND ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND ENSURE THAT
MILITARY OVERSEAS A VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES CAN REGISTER TO
VOTE FIFTEEN DAYS OR LESS.
BEFORE AN ELECTION IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE
COMMUNICATED WITH WHEN THEY ARE
AGAIN ELIGIBLE TO REGISTER TO
VOTE. AND IT IMPROVES RECORD
MANAGEMENT. TO AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN ONE WAS TAKEN TO CLARIFY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE CAN ISSUE
CONSISTENT STATEWIDE REGULATIONS
FOR THESE NEW PROCEDURES. THE
SECOND WITH AN URGENCY CLAUSE
BUT EVERYONE TO REGISTER TO VOTE
IN ADVANCE OF THE UPCOMING
PRIMARY ELECTION THE PRO
DEMOCRACY PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO
DECEIVE NO NO VOTES THE AUTHOR
HAS WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BUILT ON SB FIVE BEFORE. THANK
YOU MISTER BRIAN. SENIOR MEMBERS
WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED. MISTER
BRANDI WHICH TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY AVAILABLE. THANK
YOU MISTER BRIAN THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE THEIR DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS BILL IS AN URGENCY
ABOUT IT REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR
VOTES. ALL THOSE VOTE WE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTES WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. OR OR.
THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY
THE VOTES EISERT FORTY FIFTY
SEVEN KNOWS AT ZERO ON THE
URGENCY. I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR NEWLY ELECTED.
MEMBERS WE WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR NEWLY ELECTED
REPUBLICAN LEADER MR GALLAGHER.
MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR SOME BRIEF REMARKS. I THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS-
IT'S- MY HONORED TO BE ENTRUSTED%
WITH THIS NEW ROLE BY MY **** IS
- AND I. WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO PAY TRIBUTE TO MARIE WALDRON
- WHO'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS
LEADERS. A FOR OUR CAUCUS IN HIS
EYES LET US.
HE IS LET US A
THROUGHS. SOME TOUGH TIMES IN
OUR CAUCUS AND NAVIGATED US WELL
AND SHE DID IT ALL WITH GRACE
COMPASSION AND VISION. AND SO WE
ARE WE ARE TRULY INDEBTED TO HER
AND HER LEADERSHIP. AND IN MY
ROLE I PLAN TO BUILD UPON THAT
THAT GREAT LEGACY- AND YOU CAN
EXPECT FROM THIS REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IS ALWAYS THAT WE WILL
STAND UP. FOR IMPROVING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE OF EVERY
CALIFORNIANS. ENSURE THAT EVERY
KID HAS ACCESS TO A QUALITY
EDUCATION. TO ENSURE THAT WE
ADDRESS THE HIGH COST OF LIVING
IN THE AFFORDABILITY CRISIS- IN
THE STATE. THE HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE STATE WE ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS AND HELP
PROVIDE A PATH OUT AND EFFECTIVE
PASSED OUT. I TO ADDRESS ALL
THESE GREAT ISSUES. FACING OUR
STATE. AND AS ALWAYS WE WILL
SEEK COMPROMISE WITH OUR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES TO REACH
THOSE ISSUES AND THE FINAL
SOLUTIONS- BUT WE WILL ALSO BE A
STEADFAST VOICE OF OPPOSITION TO
MEASURES THAT UNDERMINE- THOSE
GOALS- AND I WILL END WITH- IN
PAYING TRIBUTE TO OUR TO THE
WORDS OF OUR SPEAKER WHO IS MUCH%
MORE SUCCINCT THAN I AM. LET'S
GET TO WORK THANK YOU. GALLAGHER
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVES THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE BOTH
WE WILL FIRST TAKE UP FILE ITEMS
EIGHTEEN IN NINETEEN ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSE
OF HAVING DIALOGUE THERE'S- THE
CLERK WILL READ THE RESOLUTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SOLUTION EIGHTY FOUR VIA MEMBER
HOLDEN REALTY TO THE ANNA OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAIR PAY ACT INCIDENT
RESOLUTION 62% OF RUTHERFORD AND
OTHERS REALLY TO RIVER DOCTOR
MORE LUTHER KING JR. THE CLERK
WILL NOW OPEN THE- OF THE
OFFICES RESOLUTION. MEMBERS OF
THIS IS RECALL THERE IS ALL
MEMBERS IS TO GO ALL MEMBERS
JUST TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS DESIRE
TO GO. MA'AM IF YOU WISH TO YOUR
NAME AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
STREET ON CONSENT PLEASE VOTE
NOW. SEEING AND HEARING THAT THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR. THIS MESSAGE
FROM EIGHTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA RELATIVE TO THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR PAY ACT. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR ON THE- THIS ARTICLE
. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE WILL CLOSE ROLE AND.
AND I SIXTY KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CAL IS A. THE CLERK WILL
READ THE ROOM I KNOW ON THE CAN
HELLO SENATE CONCURRENCE. SIXTY
TWO. I SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY. MISTER FLORA YOUR
RECOGNIZE AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER POLITICS. IN
THE EARLY MORNINGS OF MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST BY CAPTAIN
THAT'S WHAT UNIT WAS SHOT AND
KILLED IN A FIRE STOCKTON.
FIREFIGHTERS QUICKLY
ADMINISTERED EMS TO THEIR FALLEN
BROTHER TRANSPORTED LOCAL
HOSPITAL WHERE HE DIED OF HIS
WOUNDS AFTER FOURTEEN WAS FORTY
SEVEN YEARS OLD BUT TWENTY ONE
YEARS IN THE FIRE SERVICE HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE AND TWO
CHILDREN. WE HOLD IN OUR HEARTS
AS THEY GRIEVE THIS HORRIFIC
LOSS. OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY FRIENDS HIS BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN STOCKTON FIRE
DEPARTMENT. LAST TUESDAY THERE
WAS A CLOSE MEMORIAL SERVICE FOR
FRIENDS AND FAMILY. AS WELL
UNIFORMED FIREFIGHTERS WHO
TRAVEL FROM ALL OVER THE STATE
IN THE COUNTRY TO PAY THEIR
RESPECTS. THE SERVICE WAS
FOLLOWED BY A VEHICLE PURSUIT
PROCESSION WELL RESIDENTS
ONLOOKERS WAVE FLAGS TO SHOW
THEIR SIGN OF SUPPORT. LAST WEEK
THE GOVERNOR ORDERED THE FLAG TO
THE STATE CAPITOL BE FLOWN AT
HALF MAST IN FOR TWO IS HONOR IT
TODAY I ASKED WE DURING. THE
STATE ASSEMBLY IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER FLORA WE WILL
NOW LIFT AT THE QUORUM CALL IN
THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. MEMBERS
WE STILL HAVE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY REMAINING PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS FOR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
FOR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO ADJOURNED IN MEMORY AND IN
HONOR OF THE LATE MARTY
MORGANSTERN. PASSED AWAY ON
FEBRUARY FIFTH. MARTY WAS THE
GRANDSON OF IMMIGRANTS THE FIRST
COLLEGE GRADUATE IN HIS FAMILY
AND A LONG TIME LABOR LEADER. HE
MADE HIS NAME AS A TOUGH
NEGOTIATOR FOR BOTH UNIONS AND
STATE GOVERNMENT. GROWING UP IN
NEW YORK HE FIRST BECAME A SHOP
STEWARD WITH THE CITY'S WELFARE
CENTER AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT HE BECAME PRESIDENT OF THE
SOCIAL SERVICE EMPLOYEES UNION.
Mí
WORKED AS AN AREA DIRECTOR FOR
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES.
BEFORE HE JOINED THE CALIFORNIA
STATE EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. AS
A SENIOR CSEA NEGOTIATOR HE MET
JERRY BROWN AND WAS RECRUITED TO
SERVE AS HEAD OF THE NEW
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS. WELL THERE HE HELPED
CREATE THE LANDMARK COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING STATUTES THE RALPH C.
DEALS ACT FOR STATE EMPLOYEES.
MARDI CONTINUE TO SERVICE STATE
GOVERNMENT IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
FOR THE NEXT THIRTY YEARS STEP
BY STEPPING BACK BRIEFLY IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR TO DO
PRIVATE CONSULTING WITH LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS. I GRAY DAVIS'S
REQUEST HE RETURNED TO STATE
GOVERNMENT AS THE HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PERSONNEL
ADMINISTRATION. BEFORE STEPPING
DOWN AGAIN IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN HE
BECAME SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY. IN A TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE INTERVIEW MARTY
REFLECTED. ON THE QUALITIES OF A
GOOD PUBLIC SERVANT. QUOTE I
DON'T THINK PUBLIC SERVICE IS
DIFFERENT THAN PRIVATE SERVICE
WHAT MAKES ONE SUCCESSFUL IS
TAKING WORK SERIOUSLY AND
FINDING WAYS TO DO YOUR JOB
BETTER. I HAD A HUNDRED JOBS.
ONCE WHEN WORKING IN A PAWN SHOP
I VOLUNTEER TO PICK UP THE MAIL
OF THE REGULAR GUY WHO DID IT
WAS A WAY I WAS REWARDED WITH A
WEEK'S VACATION EVEN THOUGH
MANAGING YOU. I WAS LEAVING AT
THE END OF THE SUMMER. THEY ALSO
BOUGHT ME ANOTHER PART TIME JOB
AND I WAS IN COLLEGE AT THE TIME
. YOU SHOULD ALWAYS DO YOUR BEST
WHETHER YOU'RE REWARDED OR NOT.
AS CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE I'M
HONORED TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
A MAN WHO DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO
PUBLIC SERVICE. ENTERPRISE
DURING THE RIGHTS OF WORKERS
ACROSS THE NATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA MR COOLEY
ARE RECOGNIZED AT. COLLEAGUES I
TO RISE IN. HONOR OF MY
CONSTITUENT MARTY MORGANSTERN.
IT IS THE NATURE OF HUMAN
ENDEAVOR THAT IF PEOPLE HAVE
PARTICIPATED OVER A LONG SPAN OF
TIME IN A COMMON ENTERPRISE YOU
HAVE FOR THIS EXPERIENCE. THERE
ARE THE HAPPY FEW. AND JERRY
BROWN WITH SERVE TWICE AS
GOVERNOR HE HAD HIS BAND OF
HAPPY FEW PEOPLE WHO TIME AND
AGAIN RESPOND TO CALL OF PUBLIC
SERVICE- MARTY MORTGAGE TERMS
ONE OF THESE DIANA DOOLEY BOB
STERN I DONALD TURNER IN THE
HOUSING FIELD- WHEN GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN APPOINTED MARTY
SECTOR OF THE LABOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. UPON IS TWENTY
ELEVEN RETURN HE WAS TAPPING AN
OLD FRIEND. AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SENDS A SAID MORGENSTERN WAS
APPOINTED DIRECTOR OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS BY GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE.
AND HOW THAT APPOINTMENT CAME
ABOUT AS CLASSIC JERRY BROWN. AS
JERRY RECALLED IT. I FIRST MET
MARTY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
IN A JAPANESE RESTAURANT
SACRAMENTO. HE WAS TALKING IN A
VERY LOUD VOICE A FEW TABLES
AWAY. I HAD A BRIEF ENCOUNTER
MARTY DURING A MEETING WITH
CSEA. I WAS IMPRESSED WITH HOW
HE HANDLED HIMSELF. SO JERRY
SAID I WENT OVER TO HIM. AND
SAID HE SHOULD COME WORK FOR ME
WHICH HE SOON DID. IN NO TIME
ALREADY HAS SET UP THE FIRST
OFFICE OF EMPLOYEE RELATIONS IT
WORKED GREAT HE WAS IN THE
MIDDLE SOLVING COUNTLESS
EMPLOYEE ISSUES. ALWAYS QUICK
BUT VERY FAIR. EVERYBODY TRUSTED
HIM MARTY WAS TRULY UNUSUAL
FORCEFUL WINDS AND A GREAT
FRIEND. AND IF THERE'S LOOK AT
MARTY'S RECOLLECTION OF THAT
SAME EXPERIENCE ON THE RECEIVING
END OF JERRY BROWN. HE TOLD THE
SACRAMENTO BEE YEARS AGO THAT HE
WAS LOWERED FOR THE LABOR SIDE
OF THE TABLE BY BROWN'S
COMMITMENT TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. HE HELPED SHAPE THE
PIONEERING LEGISLATION ALLOWED
COLLECTOR BARBER SAID BOYS THE
ROUTE DEALS ACT. A GRAY DAVIS
LATER TOLD THE BEE THAT
MORGANSTERN KNOWS HIS JOB BETTER
THAN ANYONE ELSE. HE WENT ON TO
SAY TRUTH BE TOLD HE INVENTED IT
. AND I DID IT ONE MORE RESTORED
DID STEP AWAY FROM THE OFFICE OF
EMPLOYEE RELATIONS TO TAKE ON
THE ROLE OF DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA'S PERSONNEL
ADMINISTRATION A POST HE HELD
FIRST FOR JERRY BROWN AND THEN
THE SECOND TIME UNDER GOVERNOR
GRAY DAVIS. HE WAS NOT JUST A
PRINTER BROWN THOUGH WHO'S VERY
COMMITTED TO. HIS WORK. MOST OF
CALIFORNIA'S MAJOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING LAWS WERE PASSED
DURING BROWN'S TENURE BETWEEN
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THREE. THOSE INCLUDE THE
EDUCATIONAL POINT RELATIONS AT.
STANFORD BARGAINING RIGHTS IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE ROUSEY DEALS ACT
EVERY STATE WORKERS BARGAINING
RIGHTS. AND THE HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS ACT
ALLOWING COLLECTIVE BARGAIN
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS. I'M
HONORED TO RISE AND MARTY
MARSTERS READ TODAY. ONE OF
JERRY BROWN'S HAPPY FEW. IN A
LONG SERVICE OF THE PEOPLE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY MISTER VEHICLE YOU
WITH YOU'RE RECOGNIZE NOW AFTER
FOR YOUR DREAM AND MEMBER THE
NEW HAMPSHIRE- TWO WEEKS AGO WE
HAD A FIREMAN THAT GOT KILLED IN
ITS LEASE A BLACK GUY ON OUR- IN
OUR IN OUR DISTRICT. IN OUR TOWN
STOCKTON. MAX CAPTAIN MAX FOR
TUNA. IT WAS AN HONOR FOR ME TO
BE THERE TO BE PRESENT THERE. I
DON'T KNOW MAX BUT- WHEN I
WALKED AWAY FROM THERE I FELT
LIKE A REALLY. I HAVE KNOWN OF
BY A FRIEND OF MINE THAT I'VE
HUNG OUT YEARS LIKE WHEN THOSE
FRIENDS THAT YOU SEE YOU HAVEN'T
SEEN FOR A LONG LONG TIME BUT
WHEN YOU SEE HIM. IT'S ACTIVE IT
WAS YESTERDAY. AND I GOT THE
pHOW HE HANDLED HIMSELF. HE WAS.
ONE OF THOSE. FIREMAN'S THAT
THEY CALL. THEIR GUIDE THEIR
BOYS RIGHT BECAUSE HE TEACHES A
NEW FIREMAN THAT COMES ON AND
HIS JOB WAS A REALLY TO DO THAT.
AS A CAPTAIN HE LIKES HE WAS A
LEADER BUT HE HE WOULD SPEND THE
TIME TO GO OUT AND HELP OTHERS
NOT JUST IN HIS. STATION THAT HE
WOULD GO OUT TO OTHER STATIONS
TO HELP OTHERS. I GOT THIS HERE
FROM THE KIDS I GOT TO HEAR FROM
OTHER FIREMAN. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU
HEAR OF. WHAT'S GOING ON OUR
COMMUNITY IN HERE THAT YOU GOT.
GOOD LEADERS LIKE. CAPTAIN MAX
FOR TUNA. IT'S SUCH A GOOD WARM
FEELING I GOT TO GO OUTSIDE AND
SEE ALL THE FIRE ENGINE TRUCKS
THAT CAME FROM EVER FROM SAN
DIEGO LONG BEACH. IN THE BAY
AREA I MEAN IT WAS REALLY HEART
FELT. BUT WALKING AWAY. KNOWING
THAT I DIDN'T KNOW THIS MAN BUT
I FELT LIKE I WALKED AWAY AND I
TOOK A PART OF WHAT I HEARD. T.
HERE TO THE CAPITAL. SO THAT WE
CAN SHARE. AND MAX WAS SUCH A
SUCH A GREAT MAN A GREAT FATHER
A GREAT LEADER. AND MAY GOD
BLESS HIM AND HIS FAMILY AND MAY
GOD BLESS ALL THE FIREFIGHTERS
RIGHT NOW. YOU KNOW AND I JUST
WANTED TO HONOR HIM. AND
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER B. AS PER
WHAT WILL NOW RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF YOUR QUERY. AT YOUR
DESK FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF BOB HIS STONY A
THIRD GENERATION NAPA VALLEY
NATIVE SON RECYCLING VISIONARY
WINERY OWNER AND FRIEND TO SO
MANY AND A FRIEND THAT I MET AS
I ON MY TRIPS TO THE VALLEY. BOB
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY
SIX THAT IS HOME IN ST ALINA HE
WAS EIGHTY FOUR. ALMOST A
CENTURY AFTER HIS GRANDFATHER
FOUNDED HIS ORIGINAL WINERY IN
THE HELL MOUNTAIN REGION BOB
BROUGHT THE FAMILY BACK TO THE
WINE BUSINESS AND STARTED THE
RUTHERFORD. GROVE WINERY. NOW
KNOWN AS BOSTONIANS FAMILY
ESTATE WINERY HONORING THE
FAMILY'S HISTORY AND TRADITIONS
. AS A YOUNGSTER BOB LOVE
PLAYING SPORTS. ONE OF THE
FAVORITE LESSONS HE CARED FOR
THE REST OF HIS LIFE CAME FROM
HIS WRESTLING COACH. FOR EVERY
PERSON THERE'S A COUNTER MOVE TO
FREE YOURSELF IT'S YOUR JOB TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT MOVIE IS.
AFTER HIS FATHER'S DEATH IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT BOB TURN
THE FAMILIES FARMS FOCUS FROM
DERRY AND CHICKENS TO HOGS WHICH
ULTIMATELY LAUNCH BOB INTO THE
RECYCLING INDUSTRY. AT A HOG
AUCTION BOB MIDDAY HOG FARMER IN
GARBAGE MAN THAT HELP BOB SECURE
A WASTE HAULING CONTRACT FOR
THE- FOR THE UPPER NAPA VALLEY.
BEFORE MOST PEOPLE WERE THINKING
ABOUT THE VALUE OF SUCH THING IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE UPPER
VALLEY DISPOSAL SERVICE WAS BORN
AND THE COMPANY EXPANDED INTO
RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING. FOBS
WORK CREATING A SYSTEM FOR
PROCESSING WINE GRAPES PROMISED
INTO CERTIFIED ORGANIC COMPOST
WON HIM RECOGNITION FROM THE
NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC. ORGANIC
MATERIALS RESEARCH INSTITUTE AND
MANY OTHERS. IN A BAR WAS TRULY
A PIONEER IN THE WASTE INDUSTRY
HAVING TESTED AND BUILT A FULLY
INTEGRATED COMPANY A COMPANY
SPECIALIZING IN RECYCLING
COMPOSTING WASTE COLLECTION AND
DISPOSAL AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCTION. HIS WORK WASN'T THE
STUFF OF SOCIAL MEDIA MEDIA BUT
IT WAS MEET MEANINGFUL. AND
SIGNIFICANT. BARBARY BE REMEMBER
FOR HIS WARMTH HIS GENEROSITY
AND HIS INFECTIOUS SMILE HE WAS
QUICK TO GREET ANYONE WHO WALKED
INTO A ROOM AND HE MADE THEM
FEEL WELCOME AT HIS TABLE. MOST
OF ALL HE GENERALLY LOVE PEOPLE
AND LIFE. AND HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MATH MISSED. I SEND MY DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES TO THOSE BOB LEAVES
BEHIND. HIS WIFE SYLVIA FOR
CHILDREN ANDY GREG CHRISTIE AND
JOHN HIS BROTHER MARVIN SISTER
IN LAW CHARLENE AND HIS SIX
GRANDCHILDREN. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN AND JOINING IN THE
MEMORY OF BOB TO STONY A MAN
WHOSE GENEROSITY WARMTH AND JOY
MADE EVERYONE FEEL LIKE FAMILY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM WE ARE RECOGNIZED
AT HER DESK FOR YOUR JUDGMENT IN
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF MR SIGMUND BURKE
AND EIGHTY FIFTY CONSTITUENT AND
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR. WHO PASSED
NINETY EIGHT. MR BURKE WAS BORN
AS SIGMUND BURKE OF X. ON MARCH
FIFTH NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR INTO
HARPER HUNGARY. AS EARLY AS AGE
EIGHT OR NINE HE COULD RECALL
THE NOTICEABLE RISE IN ANTI
SEMITISM IN HIS SMALL VILLAGE.
HIS PARENTS LOST THEIR TAVERN
AND GROCERY BUSINESS AS A RESULT
. BURKE VIVIDLY REMEMBERED AND
KNOCK ON THE DOOR AT THREE AM ON
APRIL FIFTEENTH NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR. NEWS WAS DELIVERED THAT HE
AND HIS FAMILY WOULD BE DEPORTED
AND EVENTUALLY SEPARATED. WITH
BURKE LANDING IN THE INFAMOUS
DEATH CAMP OF AUSCHWITZ. IN THE
SPRING OF NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
BURKE MADE THE BRAVE DECISION TO
ESCAPE IF HE COULD AND HE DID HE
RAN FOR HIS LIFE HIDING FOR
EIGHT DAYS BEFORE MIRACULOUSLY
STUMBLING UPON U. S. TROOPS IN
GERMANY. WHERE HE WAS THEN
LIBERATED. HE DISCOVERED THAT
HIS FATHER AND HIS BROTHER HAD
ALSO SURVIVED WELL AS MOTHER
SISTER AND NEPHEW HAD NOT. BURKE
MET HIS WIFE OF FIFTY YEARS IN
SWEDEN. SHE TOO WAS A SURVIVOR
FROM HUNGARY AND THEY MOVED TO
LOS ANGELES. WHERE HE EARNED A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN ENGINEERING
FROM CAL STATE LA AND BECAME A
HIGH LEVEL ENGINEER A JOB THAT
HE EXCELLED AT FOR OVER THREE
DECADES. AN OPTIMIST IN EVEN THE
DARKEST OF CIRCUMSTANCE. BURKE
ONCE REMARKED THAT THE NUMBERS
TATTOOED ON HIS BODY IN
AUSCHWITZ. THAT UGH THESE
TATTOOS WERE SO COMMON. FOR
HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS HIS NUMBER
WAS. EIGHT TWO EIGHT THREE ZERO.
AND HE ADDED THOSE NUMBERS UP IT
ADDED TO TWENTY ONE AND HE
DECIDED TO PERCEIVE THIS IS A
LUCKY NUMBER MATCHING
CONSIDERING THAT TATTOO A LUCKY
NUMBER. HE BELIEVES AS A RESULT
QUITE ACCURATELY THAT HE WOULD
SURVIVE ONE OF THE MOST SINISTER
EVENTS IN HUMAN HISTORY. BURKE
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS A PROUD
HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR A TEACHER OF
THE HOLOCAUST STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER CROSSWORD PUZZLE
AFICIONADO SELF TAUGHT VIOLINIST
STUDENT OF LIFE WINSTON
CHURCHILL LOVER AND A DEVOTED
SPOUSE. WHO WAS LOVED BY ALL WHO
KNEW HIM. EGGMAN BURKE'S
REMARKABLE STORY OF SURVIVAL
RESILIENCE AND A LIFE WELL LIVED
ARE TESTAMENT TO THE STRENGTH
AND RESILIENCE OF THE HUMAN
SPIRIT. AND HE HAS SURVIVED MR
BURKE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
CHILDREN. BOB DAVID AND ROBIN AS
WELL AS HIS DAUGHTER IN LAW
LAURIE AND THREE GRANDCHILDREN
MS MEMORY BE A BLESSING AND I
ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF EGGMAN BURKE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIVES ANY ERROR
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE THAT HAS BODY TO
ADJOURN. IN THE MEMORY OF MR
ROCKIES DOMINIQUE. BRIEF BEEZER.
MR BEAZER IS KNOWN BY MANY AS
RAH RAH WHO WAS BORN ON OCTOBER
TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN NINETY
THREE. IN BELLFLOWER CALIFORNIA
THE DONOVAN AND CYNTHIA BEEZER.
ACCORDING TO HIS FAMILY. ROCKIES
WAS A VERY QUIET AND SHY YOUNG
MAN BUT NEVER SHY ABOUT HIS LOVE
FOR HIS MOTHER. HIS MOTHER WAS
THE LIGHT IN HIS EYES. HE HAD A
GREAT BOND WOULD NOW HIS MOTHER
HIS FATHER BUT ALSO HIS BROTHER
REGGIE AND HIS YOUNGER SISTER
RAVEN. HE LOVED HIS MOTHER
FATHER SISTER AND BROTHER DEARLY
BUCKY'S LOVED TO PLAY SPORTS-
THE CARSON RECREATION PARK
PROGRAM. HE WAS ALSO BAPTIZED AT
EARLY AGE AT THE MALL BEULAH
MISSIONARY BAPTIST CHURCH WHERE
HE SERVED AS A JUNIOR USHER. HE
LOVED HIS COMMUNITY AND HE LOVED
THE LAW WITH ALL OF HIS HEART
ROCKY'S LOVE TO ROLLER SKATE.
HIS FAVORITE QUOTE AND I QUOTE
ALL I NEED IS THIRTY MINUTES TO
ROLL AND I'M GOOD. EVERYONE WHO
KNEW HIM REMEMBERED HIS WARM
PERSONALITY IS AMAZING SMILE AND
HIS POSITIVE ENERGY. HE WAS
LOVED BY SO MANY. ROCKY'S
ATTENDED BROAD ACRES ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. ST ALBERT THE GREAT AND
BOURBON DAY HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE
GRADUATED. HE WAS ALSO
INTERESTED IN FASHION AND
PHOTOGRAPHY. AND CONVINCED HIS
PARENTS TO BUY HIM A CAMERA
WORTH ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
CHRISTMAS. HE GRADUATED FROM
COLLEGE THIS PAST DECEMBER HE
WAS SCHEDULED TO BEGIN A
PROFESSIONAL INTERNSHIP LATER IN
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
TWO. MEMBERS ON JANUARY TENTH.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO. THIS
YOUNG MAN WAS MURDERED. BY A
GUNMAN I WOULD SIMPLY SAY A
COWARD. IN HIS OWN NEIGHBORHOOD
. WHERE HIS FATHER SERVED THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND STILL SERVE TODAY. HE WAS
SHOT DEAD IN THE CITY OF CARSON.
AND HE WAS ONLY TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS OF AGE. HE WAS OUR SON OUR
BROTHER OUR FRIEND. HE LOVES
SPORTS ROLLER SKATING HE LOVED
HIS FAMILY. WE LOVE THE LORD
WITH ALL HIS HEART HE WILL BE
MISSED BY MANY MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF OUR-
DOMINIQUE. BEEZER THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS. THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
FEBRUARY TENTH NO SESSION NO
CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY FEBRUARY
FOURTEENTH. FLOOR SESSION IS AT
ONE PM. ALL I FOR THEIR ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASS AND
RETAIN OUR MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MYSTERY AS MOVES AND MISTER
GIBSON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH AT ONE PM.